We will not talk about RAID 3
because it's very rarely used today.
So we will go to RAID 4,
which is actually not very often used,
but it helps understand how it works,
to understand how RAID 5,
which is more often used, works.
Raid 4 uses a technique called
block interleaved parity.
It uses N disks and N minus 1, all but
1 of these disks contain data,
which is right across these disks just
like in RAID 0 and then the last disk
has the parity blocks that protects all
of the blocks of the N minus 1 disks.
So let's look at an example
with four disks.
So we said that three of
the disks contain data, so
this would be stripe zero.
Then here we have stripe three,
four, and five, and so on.
So we just distribute out
data across all but one disk.
And then we take
the date of stripe zero,
xor the whole stripe bit
by bit with stripe one.
Xor the whole thing with stripe two and
what we get will be as long as a stripe.
And that gives us the parity stripe for
zero, one,
and two and
we put that on the fourth disc.
Then we go to the next stripe
on each disc, xor them and
that gives us the parity stripe,
for these three stripes and so on.
So the idea here is that if,
let's say one disk fails,
we have the data of the two disks here,
and we have the parity.
We can reconstruct what was on the first
disk by exporting these three.
Or if there is an error in just for
example this one stripe gets too damaged
to reconstruct by using the error
correction code of this disk
in that case again, we can read this
stripe, this stripe and the parity.
And then reconstruct what should
have been the bits of this.
So effectively, now we can tolerate
the failure of any one disk.
But the cost is not two times as many
disk as we need to store the data.
Here for example, we are paying only one
quarter of the whole system is spent on
parity, and three quarters on the data.
Whereas with mirroring,
we would've spent half of the overall
capacity of the system on the mirroring.
You can think of Raid 4 as kind of
a more general technique than mirroring,
because in reality using two discs for
RAID 4,
it's very similar to mirroring because
here we will store the bits of the data,
and here we will store the same bits.
Because a bit, when you don't export
it with anything, you just put it here.
So mirroring is just an extreme
case of RAID 4 when N is just two,
but you want to go to more than two with
RAID 4 because that allows you to have
lower costs while still being able
to recover from losing one disc.
So now, what does a write do?
It must write one of the data disc and
it must read and write the parity disc.
To update the parity.
Because one of the stripes have changed.
A read, however, only needs to read the
data from the disk where the data is.
We will only reconstruct
the data if that read fails.
But in the normal scenario,
where we get the data we want,
we don't even have to consult
the parity bit for reads.